joke out of it or yeah well I know
you're a hunter s Thompson fan so you
probably aware of what hunter did to Ed
muskie
oh yeah the bow game yeah yeah
absolutely
he went crazy yeah yeah literally went
crazy no a hunter it was what was it on
the Dick Cavett show that he talked
about it well there was a rumor yeah he
had taken ibogaine and I knew about that
rumor because I started it he would
drove that guy crazy to the point where
you see I think it was in New Hampshire
he was giving a political campaign
speech and he broke down yeah oh yeah he
cried yeah yeah yeah well he so hundreds
of this great thing he he he wrote about
it it was it was kind of a spoof of
campaign coverage because he he did this
whole campaign diary and then he just
kind of went into this deadpan
recitation of what sounded like a
breaking news story about him
discovering Muskies secret relationship
with a witch doctor who was providing
him with evil again and then he dug up
some file photo of muskie that looked
like this it was like and he they put
you know must ed muskie in the grips of
a nibble gain frenzy was the caption and
it was completely deadpan he never said
he was kidding never never said it was
you know not like that was fiction and
and muskie couldn't handle it I mean he
was though that was probably the first
real political trolling that went on but
and a brilliant one too because I began
is not even in that kind of a drug it's
a drug that helps people get off drugs
right yeah it's like yes oddly enough
illegal right yeah yeah in America in
America it's legal in a lot of places
but it's really great for people getting
off opiates huh it's just a ferociously
introspective drug that rewires the way
your brain deals with addictions it
literally rewires the connections
alleviates addictions on a physical and
psychological level what's the
and what does it feel like I don't know
I don't know quite a few people that
have that have had pill problems men
have gone to Mexico and taken my friend
ed clay who has it an actual Center down
there now he started it
after he had gone down there for
treatment he had a back injury I believe
it was and got hooked on pills and I was
like Jesus I gotta figure out a way to
get off these [ __ ] things and did
ibogaine and then cleared it right up
Wow and he realized like wow like this
is this is crazy that this is illegal
yeah so the one drug that hunter chose
right was actually a drug that gets
people off drugs so just even more
ironic it just had a great name yeah
that really was the original political
troll yeah yeah and he might have had a
giant effect in the election probably
did oh yeah absolutely and I don't think
it was an accident that hunters coverage
was you know that he chose that year to
do these Diaries and I remember my
father telling me about how ever a
reporter would would wait for Rolling
Stone to come out that week so they
could you know read the coverage of the
election but you know hunter kind of
took this unknown government you know
unknown senator from the Dakotas George
McGovern and made him into this because
this like Christ figure basically I
don't I don't think that McGovern would
have won the nomination without without
that sort of relentless hyping that he
gave him because they probably would
have won the presidency if it wasn't for
the vice president having that issue was
right he had gone through electroshock
therapy eagleton right yeah yeah yeah
that was that was terrible but but
fascinating you know I mean I got to
write the the introduction to the last
last version of that book and that's one
of my favorite books of all time a
[ __ ] book yeah I mean it's just like
it's such a crazy comic epic you know
yeah
it was a big influence of yours uh yeah
you know I definitely I think the the
great thing about Hunter Thompson first
of all he he just he was so incredibly
funny in a way that was completely rare
I mean you can't just train to be that
way yet you either are born with that
ability verbally or not and he just had
this completely strange four dimensional
way of looking at things and you know he
would he would watch completely boring a
campaign speech and when he got done
writing it up it was like you know a
psychedelic wrestling match or something
like that I mean it was it was so much
more interesting and bizarre and weird
and he saw these great details and and
he was just I I think it was a great
approach to journalism but you know
sadly there aren't that many people who
can pull it off because it just required
you know a surpassing literary talent
and that's that's not that's incredibly
rare what was a unique combination of
fiction writing along with like an
actual understanding analysis yeah that
was that was his great because he cuz
you're right he he would bring you in
and the the reader would would have surf
along this incredibly charged fast-paced
narrative that read like you know the
the fastest most engrossing fiction
right but he would intersperse it would
anyway and stop and pull back and do
what we call it our only still we call
them wisdoms right where you know you
just sort of stop and say here's my take
on this and those were amazing I mean he
just he just had this ability to sort of
cut through the [ __ ] and see see
things from an angle that nobody else
saw and that was a rare technique back
then the idea of the
individualized take on things nobody was
doing that and reporting back then I
mean it was nobody even thought of it as
a form as a form that you could really
experiment with I mean there were a few
people back then like Terry southern and
Tom Wolfe who were who were doing some
things like that but but Thompson was
completely unique and there hasn't been
anybody like him you know since since
then I think I think it's it's not an
accident that nobody has been able to
pull that off again